I'm Ray Britton and I'm the Scoutmaster with Troop 42 in Oak Ridge, Tennessee.
This edition of Scoutmaster Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Keep up the good work, Clark.
And now for you, Scoutmaster.
So we're headed off to the aquarium.
We're doing a trip to the aquarium and the Scouts are very excited about this
And I told them. I said you're going to see the world's largest fish tank,
And one of the tenderfoot Scouts looked at me and he said:
how in the world do fish drive a tank
Who?
Hey, thanks, I think, to Bill McFarland for that one.
If you've got a better one, send it in
And maybe you'll hear it on an upcoming podcast.
Well, everybody, this is podcast number 220..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
I'm Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag.
Oh, a nice five-star review for the podcast over on iTunes. from
it's a screen name: Draws Older Print Play.
I've been a fan of Clark's blog for years
and the podcast adds some scouting to my morning commute.
His topics are applicable to me on the other side of the world
And the frequent interview guests bring perspective to the worldwide brotherhood
and sisterhood of scouting.
Well, thank you so much for that nice review.
I sure do appreciate it.
Heard from Steve who said I really enjoyed the podcast.
It's been a great motivational tool to keep me pushing on.
I'm glad that we're able to help you out there, Steve.
In the blog this past week
one of the articles that got some response was one
on how scouts can deal with disappointment.
Tom Rosser said: I'm sure there have been times when I've dropped the ball
after taking out more than I can handle.
Well, welcome to the club.
And not being aggressive enough or willing to delegate-
Yeah, welcome to the club. on that one too.
When working with other scouts I'm always appreciative
because I know they're volunteering their time, emotion and funds
and we all know that right.
But, Tom, you're exactly right,
And sometimes we find ourselves in the throes of disappointment.
but you know we keep on working on read that article.
and the scouts deal with disappointment.
See, if you agree.
Three books from Eric Sloan.
Now I decided that I would go ahead and post this.
It's only tangentially involved with scouting,
to tell you the honest truth.
So you don't have to read this one if you don't want to.
But I've always been a big fan- since I was a boy-
of author and illustrator Eric Sloan.
He wrote and illustrated a ton of books about American history
and old tools and wood.
Steve Jarvis read that post and said:
I've used the Weather Book for years
And he's talking about Eric Sloan's Weather Book,
which I really highly recommend.
It helped me become weather-wise.
It really explains the systems and everything like that very clearly.
It's probably he probably wrote it about 50 years ago,
but it still works-
See comment on that post.
That brings back memories.
Eric Sloan's had an Eric Sloan book on the coffee table
in the living room when I was a boy.
I'll definitely have to get the Weather Book.
Yeah, definitely get the Weather Book.
I forget exactly.
I think the other two that I mentioned in that post
was the titles are Reverence for Wood
and The Diary of an Early American Boy,
both which are non-fiction and they're great little books
And they're great for you and to share with your scouts.
Let's see,
We did an infographic this week.
It's been a while since we've had an infographic,
so we put one together on Atomic Scouting Ideals
And you know, check it out.
It's not as easy to talk about.
The reason that it's an infographic is it's not something
that it's easy to talk about.
but check that one out and see what you think.
As I promised last week on the podcast,
John Wiebke, who is the scoutmaster of Troop 358
in Zionsville, Indiana,
shared his summer plans with us
about an Ontario scouting adventure.
You definitely want to check that one out.
Robert Stout did,
And he said:
we've done this trip several times with our Troop,
which is Troop 946 in Hamilton, Ohio,
Halliburton Scout Reservation.
That's a Canadian scout reservation
And thanks for the spelling correction there, Robert.
It's an awesome place in the true sense of the word
And the Algonquin experience is really great.
The video that you included brought tears to my eyes.
It's a really wonderful place
and it brings back great memories.
I urge anyone interested to simply go.
James Chaplin said great information from John
on the idea of mixing an international scouting experience
at Camp Halliburton with a high adventure program,
giving all ages of scouts in the Troop a great experience.
And John Albertine wrote in:
let's go,
John, let's go,
Let's get out,
Let's get camping,
Let's get canoeing.
I'm really looking forward to this summer.
Last week's podcast
we talked a little bit about scout accounts and everything
And Frank Maynard, our good pal,
who has a blog as well-
And it's Bob White Blather.
If you Google that you'll find Frank,
But he added a comment to the information
that we shared with you last week.
A unit can maintain scout accounts in trust
for its members to pay for scouting expenses.
As long as the member provides the money
that's deposited in the account,
there's really no issue.
There are no rules against it
and it can be a convenience for families
And that's a really good idea.
Maybe just pay in X amount into that
and then that can be withdrawn from
as a scout does activities
and then you know you re-up.
But Frank went on to say
the safest and probably most equitable approach,
as Clark recommends in the podcast,
is to continue fundraising
but use the proceeds to benefit the entire unit
Rather than allocating those funds to individuals.
And that's my plan. that's what we're doing.
I appreciate you chiming in there, Frank,
and helping me out with that advice.
Now, before we go any further,
I want to remind you if the resources
we offer at ScoutMasterCGcom have helped you,
you can return the favor by becoming a backer.
Funds from backers help make it possible
to publish all these resources
and keep them freely available to scouts all over the world
And over this past week
I want to thank Susan Paul, Ralph Johnson
and Steve Sutter
who became backers over the past week.
Thank you so very much for your generosity and support.
We really do appreciate it.
In this podcast, in Scout MasterChip
in seven minutes or less,
I am going to continue on with the High Adventure theme
And I want to talk about some myths and legends
about High Adventure
and encourage you to have a High Adventure program
for your scouts.
We've got some email to answer too,
and we've got a Scout Master's minute to share with you,
Courtesy of our friend Tom Gillard
down in Tolohoma, Tennessee,
who sent the idea to me this past week,
And that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
so let's get started, shall we
Scout MasterChip in seven minutes
or less.
So, as you heard last week
and when we were talking in the mailbag here,
I've been having an ongoing conversation
with a buddy down in Virginia, James Chaplin,
about their High Adventure plans.
I want to take a moment to encourage you
to get your own High Adventure program off the ground
Now. usually when we're talking High Adventure,
we capitalize the H
and we capitalize the A
and we think of the BSA's most popular
and heavily promoted Big Three High Adventure bases:
Fillmont, the Florida Sea Base
and Northern Tier up in Minnesota.
Council-level High Adventure programs
usually focus on putting crews together
for trips to those three destinations,
And there's a lot of council-level
High Adventure experiences out there.
But I want to tell you something:
there are hundreds, if not thousands,
of other places for Scouts to experience
a High Adventure trip.
with a little ingenuity, a little planning
and a little vision,
Every Scout should be able to participate
in some kind of High Adventure trip
at least once while he's a Boy Scout.
I want to challenge you here
to stretch your understanding
of what High Adventure is
and to go beyond your comfort zone
and to ultimately make it happen
for your Scouts.
So the first myth we wanted to spell
is: High Adventure trips
don't have to happen at a High Adventure base
or as a part of a
quote- official, unquote- program.
You can put together your own High Adventure trip.
You really really can.
It can happen anywhere.
There are state and national parks
in the country
that offer great places for hiking
and backpacking, climbing, canoeing
and kayaking.
You don't have to travel far
or go to exotic locations,
and that's another myth.
High Adventure only happens
in these distant, exotic places.
No, no,
High Adventure is not a place,
It's a state of mind,
A challenge beyond our normal weekend camping trips.
High Adventure is about
doing more than where you go.
Fillman is a great location,
but it's not High Adventure
without the right mindset
and the right participants.
Four or five days of backpacking
a couple hours drive from home,
rather than getting on a plane
and flying to some exotic location,
can be as exciting, adventurous
and rewarding as any trip.
The most important location
for High Adventure begins between your two ears.
It's your attitude.
That's what makes it High Adventure.
The next myth we wanted to spell
is: to lead a High Adventure trip,
you have to be a highly trained
High Adventure expert.
Well, you do not have to be
an expert to lead a High Adventure trip,
and I can tell you this
authoritatively because I'm no expert
and I've led plenty of them.
You'll need some important training:
weather and safety
and first aid training- all very important.
You'll also need to plan your trip
to be slightly below your estimated
skill level,
and your High Adventure does not need
to be dangerous
to be challenging.
Rely on the experience that others have had
and educate yourself about these things.
read books and practice your skills
and you're going to be plenty
expert enough to pull off a High Adventure trip.
Remember that
our scouting organization
requires certain certifications
when we're dealing with high risk activities
like swimming and boating
and climbing
and things like that.
so you may have to get certified
in some of those things
if you're going to make them a component
of your High Adventure trip,
but there is no reason that you should
wait until you are an expert
to take your scouts on a High Adventure trip.
Find something that you are confident with
and go, Just go.
The next myth is
to deal with money.
we think that High Adventure trips are going to require
some kind of really expensive equipment
or specialized stuff
that's going to cost a mint of money,
While some trips, like canoeing
or kayaking, for instance,
they do require expensive equipment.
but you don't have to buy that equipment.
it's commonly offered for rent in the locations
where it's likely to be used.
when we go up to Algonquin Provincial Park
in Ontario, Canada,
we could choose from any one of
almost a dozen different
to rent our equipment. Backpacking
is a great low cost option,
because not every High Adventure trip
is going to cost everybody a mint of money.
if you're smart,
if you use your common sense
and you do a little shopping,
you can outfit somebody for a 5 or 6 day
backpacking trip with very simple gear
right on the tail of that,
we have a general idea,
a general myth, in our minds that High Adventure
is terribly expensive.
well, it is. if you need to get on a plane
and you need to fly halfway across the country
or halfway around the world,
it's going to be kind of expensive.
but if you stay closer to home
and you plan a challenging but attainable outing,
a nice High Adventure trip
within a couple of hours drive of where you are
and you make reasonable choices
about gear, you can have
a great High Adventure trip for
hardly anything.
you may find that a trip like this
could be the catalyst that motivates
your scouts to work towards planning,
financing a really big,
expensive ambris-ish trip sometime.
if you look around,
you're going to find that there is some place
where you can go hiking and backpacking
or cycling or canoeing
for 5 or 6 days
without spending hardly any money.
it will come out to a couple hundred dollars
ahead at the very most
and it could be cheaper than that
depending on how you set it up
and you'll be out there
and you'll have this great High Adventure trip.
that really starts scouts thinking
when they've had the experience
you say you know we could go to New Mexico,
we could go to Colorado,
we could go to Wyoming,
we could go to Alaska,
we could go to Switzerland.
it all depends on if you guys want to go.
but the first big thing
is: you got to go.
if you don't go,
if you're waiting for the perfect moment,
if you're waiting until everybody can afford this big, expensive trip somewhere,
don't do that.
that backpacking trip,
that canoe trip, that cycling adventure,
that's 5 or 6 days,
that's only a couple hours drive from home-
and make it happen
and then take it from there.
the biggest thing about it is getting out of our
you know scout or chair,
getting on our feet and making this happen.
that's what's going to do it.
if you can't do it this year,
start planning for next year
and make sure your scouts have the opportunity
to take part in some kind of great
experience.
that is, folks-
and here's an answer to one of your emails-
well, let's see, we got several
great emails last week.
picked out a couple to answer here on the podcast.
Major Richard K Luckett
is an assistant
scout master with Troop 97.
I've been a fan of the website for some time.
I've printed out many articles
and taken them to meetings to help spread the knowledge.
I'm looking for some advice
about our program
at this point. our patrols get few opportunities
to work independently.
for example, the menus for camping trips
are usually planned at a meeting
and then all the foods brought by the scout master,
and he seems to get
a little over involved in these things sometimes.
recently
I planned and executed a successful camp out
where the patrols
had to work and cook independently
and everything went very well,
it did seem. the patrol leaders
ended up doing the majority of the work themselves.
the scout master also
has a tendency to worry that things won't get done
and I've tried convincing them
that if we give the scout some instruction
and we allow them the latitude to execute,
that's how they'll learn.
the scout master's afraid they will fail,
but I tried to tell him, even in failing
the boys are learning something
and that's what's important.
as long as nothing catastrophic happens,
it will be a good learning experience.
scouting is not like a job
or the military, where everybody has to show up.
if your team is constantly changing
in assets and deficiencies,
then the role of leadership becomes
even a greater challenge.
if a whole patrol doesn't show up for an outing
and you're counting on some people,
then it becomes a bit of a leadership problem.
major luck it. thank you for getting in touch.
I really do appreciate it
and I appreciate your service.
you aren't experiencing anything
that hasn't been repeated infinitely over a century
of scouting. I'm pretty sure you know that already.
you know, go back as far as you want
and you'll read of scouters encountering this-
exactly the same kind of problems
that you describe in your email-
and you've identified a number of things
clearly and I think you're doing all you can
to help move things forward
and reach some resolution with them.
but perhaps the most useful advice
I can share with you and you in turn
can share with the scout master
is defining our mission.
maybe that'll help unlock a few doors.
I can identify
with the one man show approach
when it comes to being a scout master.
I did it for a number of years myself
until I sat down because I was tired
and I thought things through
and I modified my approach.
I used to think our mission
was an orderly and efficient program,
but far from it.
our mission is helping scouts to discover
and develop in themselves
those ideals and ideas
that come from the basis of the
scout oath and scout law,
and this is an
inherently messy
and indefinite process.
one helpful thing that came to me
was differentiating between
logistical success
and mission success.
your scout master sounds like he's doing
what I did, and that is, equating
logistics failure or success
with mission failure or success.
the problem with that sort of thing
is it's just not what we
are supposed to be doing.
we have to have a high tolerance for
adversity and uncertainty,
and it's the most difficult thing
for most scouts to get about our work.
every time we institute some measure to smooth things over
and prevent logistical failure-
like going out and buying all the food
so we make sure it's there-
we're likely denying our scouts the mission
critical experiences
of making mistakes and learning from them.
any serious student of leadership
development would have to agree
that both leadership and character
developed through a process
of trial and error, and I think we
only have to recall our own experiences
to know that this is the case.
it sounds like you've got a good relationship
with the scout master, so I'm going to
suggest an experiment to you.
set up another event where it's
going to be all the scouts, where
you're counting on the patrols to function well,
the scouts to plan and execute
the entire thing. get
two lawn chairs,
set them up side by side, once for you
and once for the scout master,
and you're creating an observers post.
sit down in one chair, put the scout master
in the other and agree that the only way
you will both interact
with the scouts will be if they
enter the observation post
or you have to intervene in something dangerous
or improper, and then
sit and watch. sit
and observe, look at what's actually happening.
now you two can talk,
just don't talk to the scouts.
look for the processes that work.
look for the successes within the
perceived failures. take some notes.
think of an ornithologist
hidden in a blind observing birds
in the wild. okay, and when
the opportunity presents itself,
after the meeting, after the camp out
or after whatever the evolution of the
activity was, sit and debrief the
scouts in positions of responsibility,
using your notes, by only
asking open-ended questions.
listen for their answers, draw them out
a little bit. don't attempt to teach,
don't attempt to judge, don't attempt
to mentor. in those cases,
just ask questions. my bet
is that the end of that process,
if you do it a few times,
your scout master will see the same thing
that you do, and that is that the
scouts are actually capable of doing things.
what, what's happens when
you end up with a scouter in a one man
show scenario is
they're caring about too much about
many things. if you can divide
up what is logistical success
from mission success,
then it's going to help you
begin to see this in a whole new light.
for obvious reasons, I'm withholding
the name and the location
of the next email. my son
is 11 and this is his first year in
scouts. like any other 11 year old,
he is an extrovert and he can
be a little annoying at times. really,
11 year olds are that way.
at a meeting recently
he got verbally attacked
by an older,
bigger scout, using some
really foul language.
when my wife and I found out what was said,
we were just about came unglued.
the next Monday night the scout masters
and the other adults met with
the older scout who had gone
after my son in this way
and they gave him a service project to report,
to write on the scout law,
and he had to make a public apology.
until this is done, he was not allowed
to participate with the troop.
my wife and I kind of feel like
this is a slap on the wrist.
we think this kind of verbal bullying
creates an unsafe environment.
we don't think anybody's filed
any kind of incident report with the council
and we have asked to meet with
everyone involved again.
if this meeting doesn't go well
and they don't do what we think should be done,
we're going to pull our son out of this troop.
my question is: are we
overreacting? well,
since you asked, yes,
you are definitely overreacting a little.
certainly, scouting should be a safe place
in every sense of the word,
but this doesn't mean we're going to be able to
make it an absolutely
safe place that prevents
every single bad thing from occurring.
that's impossible.
now, this is going to sound a little strange,
so listen carefully and hear me out.
I know how upsetting it can be.
I know that your son is 11
and there was a much bigger boy.
it's tough and difficult with him
and I know that that can just be
not only terrifying and shocking.
it can really set
parents off.
we not only can't prevent bad things like this
from occurring.
I think, when it does,
we should welcome the opportunity
that had happened in a scout troop
and we have the wherewithal
to resolve situations like this.
it's going to help the younger boy out
and the older boy too.
I think it's probably more damaging to the future
of our children
to raise them in some bubble
of absolute safety
than to let them learn from occasional
difficulties. it's our hope that
scouting is always going to be a positive
and safe place
and that scouts will always conduct themselves
in the highest level of behavior
and courtesy. now, when they don't,
it can be shocking
and unsettling, and I don't minimize that at all.
okay, it's very natural
to feel that way,
but you have to realize too
that it's an opportunity to reach out
and help all the scouts involved
in the situation that you describe.
I've had this sort of thing happen before
many times over in three decades
as a scout master,
and I don't really find it all that shocking anymore.
to tell you the truth,
it's a relatively rare occurrence,
but it's familiar enough.
I would first sit down with the scout
who was doing the bullying and the attacking
of what happened.
I'd ask to tell me how his actions
either corresponded with the scout oath and law
or fell short of them.
we'd go on to discuss what would need to happen next.
I would probably guide him towards
making an apology to the scout
and a commitment to not
repeating that kind of behavior,
and once we had figured out exactly
how we'd be moving forward.
I would meet with that scout and his parents
and we would all have a discussion.
I would be leading the discussion,
but the scout is the one who needs to talk.
I would have him describe the situation
to his parents,
the discussion that we had had about it,
and then to tell his parents
what we decided needed to happen. next.
I would make sure that the parents
understood what went on
and I would tell them that they would have to assure me
that this sort of thing would never be repeated
and that, if it was,
it would probably require me to ask
their son to leave our troop.
and then the parents can take whatever actions
they see fit,
so far as corrective punishment is involved,
with their son.
I would never, ever
impose corrective punishment
like writing apology letters
or doing service projects or reports
or whatever,
and I don't suggest that this is a good idea
for anyone else.
as a matter of fact, I think taking actions like that
is a very serious mistake.
Scouters don't use corrective punishment.
we do not punish,
we do not discipline.
that's a parent's job.
what we do is we deal in proportionate
consequences.
we are partners with parents in raising their children
and we let parents know what's going on
and it's their option to employ
corrective discipline or punishment,
not ours.
let's say, you know, if a scout
misbehaves in a way
that causes some kind of mess,
well the proportionate consequences of that
is he has to clean up the mess.
but as far as I'm concerned,
his parent is going to know
that he caused a mess and he had to clean it up
and I will tell the parents:
look, we don't have any kind of room for this kind of behavior.
so you need to correct it
and send him back to us so he can participate
in the troop. and if he repeats this kind of behavior,
we're going to have problems
and it's going to put his continued participation
with our troop in jeopardy.
so there's a huge difference between those
proportionate consequences and corrective punishment.
Scouters don't
need to corrective punishment or discipline,
just use the proportionate
consequences of the action.
then, in a partnership with parents,
you let them deal with the
any kind of corrective punishment
or discipline that needs to happen with that behavior.
listen, I hope that helps.
if you have a question
or a problem and you want to get in touch with me,
you're going to find out how to do that
just after this scout master's minute
for a scout master's minute,
Norman was walking on a
beach in Florida
and he was thinking about
a problem
and he bent down and he drew
a few characters in the sand
and he came up with his solution.
now Norman was born in
Atlantic City, New Jersey,
on September 6, 1921
and he graduated from Atlantic City High School
and he became an engineering student
at Drexel University.
right up the road from me in Philadelphia
it was the Drexel Institute of Technology.
when he was there in 1947
a fellow grad student,
Bernard Silver,
overheard a supermarket executive
asking the dean of students to figure out
how to capture product information
automatically at a checkout-
I think a whole lot of the requests- and he turned it down.
but Silver went on to mention
that problem to Norman
and after talking about it for a while
and kind of working on some preliminary ideas,
they were both persuaded that they could create
the kind of technology
needed to capture product information
automatically at a supermarket checkout.
while they were convinced that they could
create this technology, they didn't really have
the details worked out.
and this takes us to the beach in Florida
and Norman making some characters
in the sand, because Norman
had been a Boy Scout
and back in the 1930s and 40s
when you were a Boy Scout you had to learn
something called Morse Code
and most of you would be familiar with. Morse Code
is a series of dots and dashes.
Norman was drawing
dots and dashes in the sand,
so he stuck his finger
in the sand and made a dot
and then he dragged that dot
into a line.
then he made a dash
and made that into a line
and these lines
that were really just long dots and dashes
helped him crack the code
on coming up with a two-dimensional
linear Morse Code.
and he went back and he shared it
with his friend, Bernard Silver
and they used a little movie soundtrack technology
and they applied for a patent
in 1949 and they got it.
so long story short,
after two decades
Norman and Bernard's patent
had been sold to the International Business
Machines Company
where IBM.
Norman was an employee of IBM at the time
and he helped them develop
the first scanning technology
that everybody uses now
whenever we go to a supermarket checkout
or convenience store checkout anywhere.
in 1971
the Universal Product Code
came into being and by 1974
the first item
was scanned in
an Ohio supermarket.
it happened to be a pack of chewing gum.
so anytime we go into a store right now,
or any product you have to hand,
has a Universal Product Code on it.
if you look at it, it's a set of lines,
and those lines
were created by former Boy Scout
Norman Woodward
based on the fact that he learned
Morse Code
when he was in Boy Scouts.
so pay attention, Scouts, because you never know
what you're going to pick up
and it's a very important part of your life:
Music,
Music.
And well, thank you for listening to this
220th edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
you can keep in touch by reading the blog
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
while you're there, you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
you can get the ScoutmasterCG app.
you can get it on Google Play
or in the iTunes App Store,
and this will help you keep all the resources we create
right there at your fingertips
on your mobile device.
you can experience the wonders of ScoutmasterCGcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
you can join the 5200
folks who like
ScoutmasterBlog on Facebook.
you can tweet along with the course of
just over a thousand tweeters on Twitter.
you can pin the Pultritudinous pictures
you can offer publicly
with 1400 other
prolific pinners on Pinterest.
you can watch us at ScoutmasterCG
on YouTube and join the 400
odd folks who form the exclusive
ScoutmasterCG circle
on Google Plus.
if you can't face Facebook,
come on. everybody, join in.
if Twitter makes you better,
if you have no interest in Pinterest,
if you don't put the? U in YouTube,
if you're a minus when it comes to Google Plus
and send me an electronic mail,
that's right.
you can email me, Clark Green,
your comments and questions
and your crazy ideas
at Clark. at ScoutmasterCGcom,
it's C-L-A-R-K-E.
at ScoutmasterCGcom,
the ScoutmasterBlog
and the Scoutmaster Podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America
or Scouting Organization for that matter.
I'm pretty sure they all have
much better things to do with their time.
no, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here's our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping
why? thank you, sir?
until next time, everyone,
you.